saxons hopsack sneeze capital dresden is
famous for its historic city center but
saxony has recently become infamous as a
hotbed of xenophobia in germany i'll be
talking about that with Dresden's mayor
dick he'll bat welcome mr. Hill Babson
fecal matter but hello tech sure does he
thank you for joining us on the DW
interviewed of human I'm Thomas bond hey
mr. Hibbert refugees have been harassed
on the bus residents applauded when
refugee hostels go up in flames and
every Monday xenophobes gather in the
middle of Dresden Linda you're from
Saxony yourself you must find this
shameful he knows every time I'm married
to a foreigner it a Korean woman we on
so the situation we're faced with is
very difficult for me the image our city
is presenting is anything but the image
I would like it too especially because
Dresden has grown in very positive ways
in the 25 years since the fall of
communism and you mr. shaft law Courtois
it has drawn people who work in the arts
and sciences mr. media and people who
work for international companies so this
is very painful for us Messerschmitts
leash wouldn t I'm Sun King listen
you're personally affected because your
wife is a foreigner have you and she
experienced any hostility there's no I'm
a PC recruiting luckily not yet my wife
told me about one incident that's really
kind of about the irony of faith another
foreigner gave her sort of a bad time
but otherwise nothing's happened
thankfully mr. visualize eats welcome
mmm about the Ellis Linda but the
xenophobes are now taking action in the
neighborhood where you live there are
citizens initiatives against foreigners
there aren't you worried for your wife's
safety of how a line don't exist by
fruits wiser it's much I'm sure you and
it does make you a bit nervous and
that's what we see in general in the
city and diamond dash that because they
just means empty Nigel people who have
come here from all over the world home
Cindy you feel completely at home here
and it is a beautiful city
or you can live and work quite well
instead are suddenly afraid when they
leave their homes discontent East one
saw my gsi justice white I know and that
is something that we simply cannot allow
dotted season Tim you were elected last
summer by a wide majority our most
resident airs live Earl and open-minded
he's nice he bajado invade often I think
so yes let's keep taught us under the
trees but there's also the other dress
that knowledge is associated with the
name pegida pop the patriotic Europeans
against the Islamisation of the West
they hold anti-foreigner demonstrations
every Monday academics that soon always
do a majority of Dresden residents
secretly support this activity I'm
Alicia meow place now nine right no
their appeal is limited around Rouen
candidate for mayor and she only got
nine point six percent of the vote I
think that's the maximum support that
really exists for Paquita and our city
is double but we see the dresden
presents a stage that is used not only
by local residents but also by others
who come here from the rest of the
country above desk least menya we've
seen that a lot of people come to these
boogita demonstrations from the czech
republic which is right next door when
to zina and development scares me cause
malnutrition come to de paquita
demonstration what does macchiato
dumpster is it Mon taking Dumont's
images from the demonstrations like an
effigy of Chancellor Merkel hanging from
a noose have made the news around the
world begin devotees who are the Paquita
supporters are they all right wing
extremists you def avenge discuss our
Eagle Alice script amitava Lumia
although several studies indicate that
this has less to do with right-wing
extremists who would presumably be
simpler to deal with two thousand we're
mostly dealing with what are called
concerned citizens victimization studies
indicate that they represent a broad
spectrum of society do they tend to have
an average income or even an above
average income there are self-employed
people mock Asian
Master Craftsmen data and people from
the Intelligencia they tend to be male
and middle-aged or older there are
certainly young people from the
surrounding region but fewer from the
city of dresden itself United Eisenhower
psyche which one but we do have to
address the question of what attracts
people to this girl Houdini died mmm
that's it see but where does this hatred
come from in the Eastern German states
immigrants make up maybe an average of
two percent of the population it's not
garnish my eyes I wouldn't describe it
as hatred first of all fear plays a role
in urban society and if you're not used
to being around foreigners you may be
afraid of them is mechana homeland as
you just said there are very few of them
in the eastern states blondes of what
was a fish news to me in Dresden there
were maybe four percent before the wave
of refugees came in an odd super dr.
long if all of a sudden a large number
of immigrants arrived and the local
residents aren't used to being around
foreigners if that can cause fear it's
okay and we have to address that what
dumb because I was not as it's more dr.
mordock with diamonds each Monday there
are Paquita demonstrations but also
counter-demonstrations it once that's
one from least not bill guy needs that
even once you've been talking to both
sides what do you hope to achieve high
commission do stuff cos appearances on i
would like to reunite our city that's my
declared gold indian we cannot allow
things to continue as they have over the
past few months we've seen the rise of
an anti Paquita movement that's happened
in other cities to host port assist but
as he can i doona i'm a fine i believe
that we have to engage in dialogue was
in under them status asia of the windows
village pense que no sirve I'm this I'm
working with church leaders to invite
people to forests for dialogue on the
serious issues that we face today hits
at super sheets in da roca for the nine
behind in previous forums have drawn
between 500 and a thousand people eyes
to equivalent I wasn't matin Emma sees
and even Indian you want to encourage
dialogue even with piggy
supporters but in some cases you've been
shouted down a computed how can you make
your case under such conditions also
need a good point I've never been
shouted down occasionally someone will
interrupt and I'll think to myself
people are pretty upset here whose do
moon but at the last event in early
februari defines of citizens express
their opinions and they did it in a very
civilized way fine china has a Dean to
see booga elem I know for Todman I think
it was a much more effective dialogue
than we had seen at previous forums my
people are listening to each other more
closely enough and that's a very
important point a poop people have got
to start talking to each other again
yemeni stay put it into your state
premier and others say that this
phenomenon is not limited to saxony this
context it exists across germany that
wound is a public you've been accused of
contributing to the escalation by
playing down the developments in saxony
your response schweet that mrs. i
wouldn't say it was played down but in
retrospect it's possible that if an
effective stance had been taken against
pegida a year ago when it was just
getting started damn eyes it might not
have become so popular ducky and
deflation Connie so pagina is active in
Dresden come to a greater extent and
they are in other cities equalizing
under the political elites decided not
to pay attention to ozone depletion but
they got a lot of attention anyway elf
nexim kite that's a game geha bums are
but I'm givin you at home with you
jurgita holds rallies every Monday you
could stop that by banning
demonstrations but you don't want to
that is that tolerating the intolerant
so i think is it if there were a legal
basis for banning those demonstrations i
would but there isn't and we have the
right to freedom of opinion and freedom
of assembly it once taught suuns those
are valuable rights and they are
protected by the Constitution that be so
i will not interfere
afternoon miss fatigue inning you too
big it wouldn't just give the Gita
something else to complain about
obviously gonna do my also i think the
political elite interprets the laws it
will and i won't do that I have to deal
with this situation openly and society
does too we have to work hard to
continue the dialogue call people's
fears and get them to talk to each other
it's not easy but it's the only option
we have otherwise it'll be swept under
the rug and then it'll all just flare up
again if I softy moon from Big Ed
complains that the borders are still
open and refugees are still arriving
common what's your opinion do we need to
limit the numbers of refugees tanguy
Galba is good I think there will have to
be a limit to the number of refugees
because otherwise the local governments
and the entire national system will be
overwhelmed not in terms of providing
shelter and I think that's still the
easiest challenge but in terms of
successfully integrating these people
then it's done was I guess a shift if
our own society our own people are not
with us like it won't be possible to do
any effective work on integration looks
I think there has to be a counterbalance
and it will come w now we can start
discussing how Germany will manage this
all come in I think there's still plenty
of room for more which despite
everything dies gabbie show no roof no
blah blah what Allah team so I'm
sometimes when you took office you
promised that Dresden would be a model
for integration is it that you submit Oh
talk we do need to work on that urgently
unless you want to play I think Dresden
is a model city when it comes to housing
different two-thirds of the refugees
have been housed in apartments
decentralized me fast Coleman on right
now we have more refugees and language
courses than a nearly any other city or
region movies activ- which I've built on
lies and it's the head of Social Affairs
recently said to me when I suggested
more projects I don't
have any more refugees they're all busy
finishing a dentist at Liam of around
five thousand refugees some 4,500 or
taking language courses so we're really
setting an example thank and four months
we've been discussing the issues of
integration we work with business
leaders so I think we're not doing so
badly as we finished here Buffy been mr.
here dad we always end our interview
with three in complete sentences that
we'd like you to finish in other mayor's
in Germany have stepped down because of
xenophobia I stay in office because ish
I owe it to the voters to complete my
turn and dresden needs a mayor who will
reunite the city I'm the one to do fine
and dandy stack via some food on this
Vinnie into makita supporters I'd say
these in that house like they're at a
dead end it's been more than a year and
we've seen that the solutions can't be
found on the street feared for my son
Lucas's future I would like Dresden to
be death rate of Antonio hunt is
open-minded tolerance and welcoming to
immigrants again have equalized dr.
Caleb at and thank you for joining us if
you're welcome